- [Voiceover] SO we've got these
three penguins, grammarians
we've got Raúl, who
you may remember from
his sweet mohawk, we've got
Cesar and we've got Gabriela.
Three magellanic penguins from Argentina.
And they are all different
amounts of happy.
Cesar is a medium amount of
happy, Raúl is more happy,
and Gabriela is the most happy.
And in English, we have
a way to compare these.
To compare Raúl to Cesar.
To compare Raúl to Gabriela,
or any combination thereof.
We call these comparative
and superlative adjectives.
And before I get too into
the weeds on that, let me
just show you what that looks like.
So we can say Raúl, let
me put in the accent,
Raúl is a happy penguin.
He's go all the fish
he wants, life is good.
Raúl is happier than Cesar.
This is what we call a comparative,
because we're comparing
Raúl to Cesar, and we're
comparing their happiness levels.
And Raúl has more happiness
in him than Cesar does.
Poor Cesar.
However, Gabriela is the happiest penguin.
Ta-da.
The happiest is something that we call
superlative in English.
So it's not just a comparison.
It's not Raúl is happier than Cesar.
Gabriela is happier than
all the other penguins.
She is the happy-est, she is the happiest,
she is the most happy.
So one way to think about
this is that Raúls happiness
is slightly larger than Cesars happiness,
but Gabriela's happiness is double plus,
is unbeatably more than both of them.
I'm gonna use a made up math symbol.
Boom boom boom, like super greater than
undisputed, she is the happiest penguin.
Because the comparative is
the same thing as saying more.
The comparative equals
more, and the superlative
equals most.
So this is slightly more,
this is super much more.
And something that's neat
about English is that
you can use the comparative
and superlative for both
positive relationships and
also negative relationships.
So we could say Raúl is a
happy penguin, and we can say
Raúl is happier than Cesar.
We can also say Cesar
is less happy than Raúl.
So this is comparative but
it's going the other way.
Right.
Cesar is less happy than Raúl.
So then we use the less than symbol.
Gabriela is the happiest
penguin, and so for this group
of three, Cesar is the least happy.
So you can use the comparative
and the superlative forms
of adjectives to compare
relationships where one thing is
more or most than another
or others, or relationships
where one thing is less
or least than others.
That's how the comparative and
superlative work, but if you
stick around for the next video,
I'm gonna talk about how to
figure out, how to form the
comparative and superlative
when you're looking at a word
you've never seen before,
like, what if we made up a word, like
like blarfy.
What do you do with that?
Well, you'll find out next time.
In the meantime, you can learn anything.
David out.